[Music]  this is manuel maverick country been a  fan since day one when the school was up  and open for school plays a big part in  the town there's not a lot of businesses  here in manville there's not a lot of  things going on I'll be unique  relationship with each player I try to  be a mentor whether it's feeding them or  you know making sure they're not up late  whatever situation but seeing a bunch of  them come and a bunch of them go they're  really special they all have something  unique in every one of them every Friday  or Thursday we cook for the whole team  anything could be on the menu up cook  hot dogs sausage on a stick chili dog  ribs brisket beef ribs pork ribs link  sausage boudin pulled pork I've tried  almost everything football is a big key  to community you can bet on Friday  nights people show up to football